two pretty good offenses as well going
head-to-head
chris bassett ready to work and handlers
staring in
he has been electric runner goes for the
1-2 and it's a line out that's going to
turn
into an easy two at first base altuve
was off and they double him up
second straight inning the astros have
had the lead runner on
and that time elevates and gets correa
to strike out first k of the day for
bass and two down
so two down two on and here's josh
reddick
the pitch to redick and reddick pops it
up and that's playable on the infield
drifting out into short left is simeon
and marcus is back there and he makes
the catch and bassett works out of it so
the astros
leave two they fail to score a walk's a
rally starter
and olson draws the walk with one away
here in the second here's chris davis
fly ball headed towards right center
field and deep back goes tucker at the
wall that ball is gone
a two-run home run for chris davis and
it's the athletics who take the
two-nothing lead here in the second
inning
an opposite field shot into the pavilion
and right off the bat of chris davis
and the a's have the early lead sean
murphy against lance mccullers
murph had the biggest hit for the a's so
far in 2020 the home run against the
white sox
and the next pitch is sail towards
center field back on it goes springer
fighting the sun
on the track at the wall and gone
kept on carrying over the 395 sign
and sean murphy has gone deep again
his second in the postseason the a's
lead at three nothing
a majestic drive to straight away center
field
my goodness i mean that was a strong
young man
and shawn murphy cannot be denied the
way he's swinging the bat bregman last
year so good 119
and you know 41 home run
this one is driven to deep left field
back goes grossman
under the track he will leap and not
make the catch
it's gone a home run to left field for
bregman
astros on the board with a long ball of
their own bregman who hit six during the
regular season
it's a home run here and the astros are
on the board in the fourth inning
off the top of the wall in left field
and bregman collects
a home run here in the division series
and the a's now lead it three to one
tucker aboard at first base
was correa getting his second look at
basset
here's the pitch and he hits this one
pretty well
straight away center field looking up
that's good wood it's
a game tying two-run homer for carlos
correa
it's three to three second home run in
as
many postseason games for correa and
both of them the center field he had won
a straightaway center at target field in
the
second game of the wild card series
[Music]
and the astros able to not the score
olson walked and scored on the davis
home run in the second
0 for 10 lifetime against mccullers sky
to deep right center springer going back
at the wall and that ball is going to
carry out of here too
matt olson 14 during the regular season
homer's here in the fourth
and the athletics had their lead back on
top four to three
more the a's have a 4-3 lead runners at
second and third and now two outs
the stella will strike out and mccullers
does a great job of getting out of any
further
trouble one out and simeon at third base
for mark cannon
lifts it to short right tucker now
backing up a step or two will make the
catch
tagging at third is simeon there'll be
no throw
and the athletics had on to their lead
on top now five to three
sac fly to right field for canna and the
a's on top by
two and maldonado with a base hit sets
the table for george springer
he'll hit this one down the line to
third into the left field corner route
from second base comes reddick
maldonado will stop at third it's an rbi
double for springer his fourth hit
and the astros are back within a run
it's now five to four
have a day george springer
that's to left field and it's in for a
base hit maldonado will score trying to
score as springer he will
and the astros take the lead all of this
is coming with two outs in the beginning
and jake diekmann checks into the game
now for the athletics
on the ground right side and by the dive
of the stella altuve will be waved
around he will score
and a 7-5 lead now for the astros all of
those coming with two outs and michael
brantley
drives in the most recent astros run
felt like anything they left up was gone
anything in the air felt like it had a
chance you're right
we've been a few of those today for the
pitchers and here's a fly ball to center
field
see if this stays in the yard luriano
going back at the wall
that's gone as correa has gone deep
again
homer to the fourth he gets a solo shot
on the seventh
and it's eight to five astros on top
third home run of the day for the astros
second for correa
first and third for the astros they've
got him at the corners with nobody out
here in the ninth
and that one is lying towards right
center field and that ball is going to
get down from third base comes bregman
with the ninth astros run and it's first
and third again
this is in the air to left field hit
deep and far as grossman goes back onto
the track to make the catch in front of
the wall
tagging at third and scoring his tucker
he is in and it's ten to five astros
nothing into the count to murphy
he struck him out and the astros have
taken game one
of the alds one two three ninth